[Musique]
ça c'est moi
encore moins toujours moi est ce que
vous entendez c'est le concerto italien
le seul bac que j'aurais jamais pu
obtenir c'est moi mais je n'aurais pas
dû je suis tomber tête baissée dans le
premier piège me laisser filmer
présentez vous m'avez tondi comme si ce
qui pouvait m'arriver de mieux ce
n'était pas que personne ne
reconnaissent l on avait ajouté
les autres ont fait vingt minutes et
bien bravo pour les autres mais moi en
dix minutes j'aurais fait le tour et
peut-être même plusieurs fois
en transformant cette ds en voiture
bureau je ne pensais pas que je ferais
couler plus d'encre et de salive que des
sens se souhaitait seulement pouvoir
continuer à travailler dans les
embouteillages parisiens
ce qui est drôle voyez vous ce n'est pas
de regarder la télévision à voiture non
c'est de regarder la tête des gens qui
vous voit en train de regarder la télé
me en fait depuis très longtemps je ne
tourne plus le bouton par plus que je
lui utilise le bar mais cela amusait
tellement le cameraman
[Musique]
à
voici mon bureau à france soir voici le
cactus qui me tient lieu de jardin
secret
[Musique]
contrairement à ce que des esprits
chagrins affirmé mêmes écrivent
je ne suis pas le journaliste le mieux
payé je suis seulement celui qui
travaille le plus c'est à dire presque
le contraire
sinon si j'avais trouvé un patron assez
avisé pour me donner autant que ce
qu'une demi douzaine de patrons me donne
j'aurai un seul job et je vivrai
normalement
[Musique]
à
si toutes les vendeuses avait ce galbe
il n'y aurait jamais eu de crise dans la
presse parisien
[Musique]
si toutes les émissions de télévision
ressembler à celle là les organisateurs
de rencontres de catch ferait faillite
si toutes les pièces étaient du même
niveau
on pourrait faire l'économie d'un
ministère de la culture un théâtre
parisien fonctionnait une personne vend
des billets et huit autres lui téléphone
toutes les heures pour savoir combien
elle en a vendu au ce n'est pas une
pièce conçue pour intéresser la critique
non mais pour divertir le public au
bureau de location
tous les mots d'auteur sont bien combien
si je suis un mauvais père un mauvais
mari un mauvais fils un mauvais citoyen
un mauvais journaliste un mauvais
confrères je dois être un bon auteur
entendez par là que je livre
ponctuellement et à domicile ici c'est
le manuscrit d' et si je disais tout qui
paraîtra dans deux semaines
[Musique]
là c'est une lettre ouverte aux
hypocrites prévue pour la fin de l'année
si tous ceux auxquels par définition
elles s'adressent l'achète
on peut prévoir un beau tir à je ne
possède aucun diplôme
alors pour compenser j'ai essayé d'avoir
des livres beaucoup de lignes leur soit
une dizaine de bouc à tous les matins
mais ce que je préfère on ne me les
envoie jamais ni molière ni stendhal ni
flaubert ni balzac n'ont jamais jugé
opportun de me faire tenir leur service
de presse
et cette bibliothèque est aussi un rêve
d'enfant montplaisir n'aurait pas été
complet sans une échelle et 100 mais
sion à sion ou savez c'est un auteur de
base pour un bibliophile sérieux on
l'achète parfois mais on ne lit jamais
ça ce sont mes oeuvres complètes que je
n'ai quand même pas osé installé entre
voltaire et rousseau en 20 ans j'aurais
pris 15 kilos et 11 me je persiste
toutefois penser avec certains de mes
détracteurs que même si j'arrive un jour
à passer le cap des 50 volumes publiés
je ne serai toujours pas un écrivain
mais seulement un journaliste qui rédige
parfois les articles de 300 pages sur
cette table j'ai longtemps perdu tout ce
que j'avais gagné à mon bureau
et puis j'ai supprimé le poker comme le
reste
je veux dire sans parvenir à le
remplacer par un autre vice
vous l'avez déjà compris je suis
prisonnier mais parfois je mets va vers
la normandie
cette petite maison était d'abord une
emplette puis elle est devenue un rachat
milieu des paysans et des vaches je
remets mieux les hommes et les
événements de la vie parisienne alors
vraie place c'est à dire très au dessous
du niveau de la mer oublie les bassesses
dans les hautes herbes
le mavi enfin que la mort d'un arbre est
plus dramatique que celle d'une
célébrité que les poires sont plus
juteuse que la plupart de mes
interlocuteurs que l'air venu de la mer
n'est pas signée francis lopez que la
seule vraie façon d'oublier qu'on sera
un jour à six pieds sous terre
cette faire pousser des légumes et du
gaz enclave béni où les tracteurs
remplacent les détracteurs et où ceux
qui parfois vous jette la pierre
entendent seulement vous aider à
dessiner votre jardin
celui là c'est miel un chien un chien
abandonné que j'ai recueilli faute
d'avoir pu trouver un bébé phoque
nous avons ensemble de longues
conversations je lis davantage dans son
regard que dans les oeuvres de
marguerite duras
c'est un ami un ami sûr et pas
encombrant il ne m'avait jamais jusqu'à
aujourd'hui demandé de parler de lui
[Musique]
je fais de la radio à rtl depuis plus de
dix ans je ne sais pas ce qu'en pensent
ceux qui m'écoutent mais moi j'aime bien
cette façon de parler aux gens dans
l'oreille sans avoir à rectifier
préalablement son noeud de cravate
et puis j'apprécie cette facilité que
les ondes me donne de montrer mon âme
sans montrer mon visage
[Musique]
je travaille aussi dans un hebdomadaire
c'est le seul moyen de prendre un peu de
recul et parce qu'on est obligé de se
manifester après les autres de ne pas
aller au plus simple au plus évidents ou
plus facile
pendant 25 ans j'ai écrit sans réfléchir
alors j'essaie maintenant parfois de
réfléchir sans écrire
[Musique]
la télévision c'est à la fois mon point
fort est mon point faible
mon point fort parce que son impact est
le plus fort de tous parce qu'une seule
émission vespérale équivaut sur le plan
des retombées à un an de radio et à 10
ans de presse écrite c'est mon point
faible parce que je ne suis pas
complètement fait pour la télévision
parce que mon visage et mon gabarit ne
sont pas de ceux qui vont avec tous les
mobiliers de téléspectateurs parce que
je n'ai pas des ans parce que chaque
fois que la petite lampe rouge s'allume
je me sens devenir un homme je fais de
la télévision comme je vais chez le
dentiste
parce que je peux respirer un grand coup
chaque fois que c'est fini parce que
c'est chaque fois un combat que je livre
plus contre moi même que contre ce que
professionnellement je suis chargé
d'agresser j'ai eu longtemps le trac je
ne l'est plus depuis que ma présence
d'infliger aux autres
la recette de l'huile sur le feu et ça
elle consiste à trouver des gens plus
méchant que soi est alors rappelé leurs
propos incendiaires s'il ne s'en
souviennent plus minute fatidique où la
gorge se dessèchent où les pulsations
augmente c'est le moment du générique
pendant 50 minutes
je vais être un autre et vive oms dans
un rêve je ne voudrais pas que vous
puissiez penser plus longtemps que pris
dans ce laborieux tourbillon qu'ayant
choisi le surmenage comme la forme la
plus rentable du suicide
je suis un garçon qui ne se pose pas de
question
les bouvard vous aimez vous eh bien je
vais vous surprendre
non je ne m'aime pas mais je me supporte
parce que je nourris trop et trop bien
d'ailleurs prétendent mais ennemi
lointain mes amis intimes et mon
tailleur moi ça m'est égal parce qu'il
ya très longtemps que mon tour de tête
m'inquiète plus que mon tour de taille
bon c'est une pirouette
enfin tout le monde dit tout le monde
répète que vous êtes méchant écoutez si
c'était vrai on ne paierai pas pour
l'être en tout cas vous vous attaquez
volontiers
faible que vous volontiers non puisque
je ne le sais jamais qu après l attaque
quel est votre rêve quel est votre
devise est bien c'est de vivre aussi
bien et aussi longtemps que ce qu'on
appelle mes victimes
j'y suis presque parvenu ce qui ne vous
aiment pas et ça fait du monde dystocie
que vous avez des nerfs c'est faux j'ai
seulement des collaborateurs d'ailleurs
je ne crois pas aux [ __ ]
s'il existait maurice druon on n'aurait
pas été ministre chargé de la culture il
se serait occupé de la coopération
bon mais vous ne pouvez pas nier que
beaucoup de gens travaillent pour vous
et avec vous ça n'est plus à reproche
depuis qu'on a dépassé le million de
chômeurs vous exhibez volontiers ce que
l'on appelle des signes extérieurs
pourquoi par goût de lait pâtes par
provocation ou par naïveté
non c'est par honnêteté au moins depuis
qu'ils sont taxés par le fisc
aimez-vous l'argent beaucoup moins que
ce qu'ils procurent
essayez-vous parfois de vous faire
pardonner d'en gagner
oui le plus souvent possible en le
dépensant parce que c'est la seule façon
honnête qu'il profite à d'autres
est il exact que vous écriviez et que
vous disiez n'importe quoi oui mais pas
n'importe comment ni sur n'importe qui
pourquoi alors que nous sommes dans la
civilisation des loisirs
travaillez-vous 14 heures par jour parce
que j'ai essayé de travailler 15 heures
par jour et alors là vraiment ça me
fatigue êtes vous vraiment un ambitieux
non non pas du tout puisque d'habitude
je me borne à poser des questions alors
que tout le monde sait que dans notre
société les gens importants ce sont ceux
qui apportent les réponses
est ce qu'on peut vous confier un secret
ah oui bien sûr surtout si on veut
qu'ils ne soient pas perdus pour tout le
monde vous souciez vous du qu'en
dira-t-on
alors est-ce que le serpent a peur du
serpent
pourquoi affectionner vous autant les
plaisanteries 2 me
goût mais par sagesse mais parce qu'il
faut savoir se contenter de ce qu'on a
j'aimerais vous remercier de m'avoir
répondu non sans vous poser une dernière
question pour quelle raison m'avez vous
accorder cet entretien pour deux raisons
la première c'est que vous êtes
finalement plus sympathique que ce qu'on
m'avait dit et puis la seconde c'est
parce que je suis un farouche partisan
du dialogue
merci
[Musique]